Sirens blared, and the loud ringing of the
emergency alarm system gave everyone a scare,
like something had jumped out at them
unexpectedly. With that fright came a
sharp jolt of adrenaline; something wasn’t
right, and their options were to either await
instructions or try and flee with their lives.
Most took the latter, dropping their shovels and
various mining tools so that they could turn heel
and bolt to the nearest opening. Outside, if they
could just get outside, above ground where the
air was a little clearer, then they could avoid…
whatever it was that was happening. But, for Yuri,
escape wasn’t an option; he had to do something.
It had been a standard operation, everything
had been run by the books and was going all the
smoother for it. But that noble approach hadn’t
stopped the drill from breaching into a cavern,
carving through stone into a previously
undiscovered cavern. That on its own
wasn’t enough to cause concern; it was the
sudden cave-in that had triggered the alarms,
and led to the ensuing panic.
At the controls of the gigantic
excavation machine, Yuri helplessly pulled at
levers and pressed buttons, desperately trying to
undo the rapidly worsening damage. But it was too
late, rocks and debris were showering from above,
like the Earth itself was retaliating against the
mining workers. It was as if they shouldn’t have
drilled that deep, the cave-in almost like they
had awakened something… unfortunately for Yuri,
a falling slab of stone made sure
he wouldn’t get to see exactly what.
The dust settled shortly after,
but only one recorded casualty,
along with multiple injured mine workers, wasn’t
enough to deter them from exploring what they
had accidentally stumbled upon. Venturing
into the cavern system pierced by the drill,
those who first dared to set foot down there
were greeted with the sight of strange,
crudely built stone structures. Someone had
been here before, but how? Nothing could
survive this far below ground… nothing living,
nothing human at least. And that was true,
given that the workers also came across something
else in their initial exploration… human remains.
Of course, this raised quite a concern, prompting
the workers to try and contact their superiors.
Uncovering bodies wasn’t exactly uncommon for
anyone whose job it was to dig into the ground,
so they at least had a protocol in place for
this kind of situation. What none of them were
prepared for, however, was the fiery abomination
that suddenly emerged as they were trying to call
for help. The creature was a nightmarish blend
of a humanoid shape, with the head of a dog and
giant wings much like a bat’s. Covered in
rough fur, its body was exuding an oily,
flammable substance… which it used to incinerate
the surviving mine workers in an instant.
By the time that operatives of the SCP Foundation
arrived on the scene in the town of Mirny,
within the Sakha Republic, the creature was
on a rampage. Buildings were collapsing as
the winged beast set the nearby area ablaze.
Troops on the ground, even once they were able
to get the monster in range, found that their
conventional weapons were useless. It cost the
lives of seventeen Mobile Task Force operatives –
all immolated down to a cinder – before a chopper
was able to neutralize the creature.
With the threat destroyed, and the town
administered with amnestics and fed a convincing
cover story, you’d think that was case closed on
a job well done. But the Foundation discovered,
within the nearby Mirny mine, something that
would completely change everything they thought
they knew. Deep underground was a sinkhole,
leading to a spatial anomaly below, consisting of
the system of caverns that the mine workers had
inadvertently stumbled upon. That wasn’t all that
the Foundation was about to discover down there;
and what they came across would soon become
one of their darkest secrets: SCP-3667
It wasn’t long before the Foundation began
encountering other unusual creatures that
seemingly appeared in the vicinity of SCP-3667.
However, not all of them matched the description
of the original, bat-winged, dog-headed,
pyromaniacal visitor. Officially dubbed
as instances of SCP-3667-1, these creatures
ranged from the aforementioned monstrosity
to a whole host of other strange descriptions.
One was an abnormally thin humanoid creature,
with reddish-brown skin and a head that was
too big for its wiry body. It possessed an
ordinary human level of intelligence, and even
spoke modern Russian, matching the common local
dialect. In conversation, this being tried
to offer wealth or power in exchange for
a person’s most valued possessions. However,
it seemed to possess no anomalous abilities,
and would attempt to renegotiate a new offer
immediately after a bargain was made. Then,
there were the ‘magistrates’; a group of
forty-eight humanoids with kyphotic curved
spines. All of them wore furs, and a variety of
skulls from animals such as elks, deer, and moose.
The Foundation were still none the wiser as to
the true origin of all these different subspecies
of creatures. They were obviously emanating from
the sinkhole, and the Foundation had been making
use of MTF Chi-5, codenamed ‘Solomon’s SEALs’ to
eliminate instances of SCP-3667-1 that appeared
from below. Surface-to-air missile systems were
even installed nearby, should any more flying
creatures appear. But further exploration into the
sinkhole, and the caverns below, would only yield
further questions… and even more strange entities.
The four-person unit MTF Chi-5 Team One was sent
in to conduct preliminary exploration into
SCP-3667, to try and assess more accurately
the threat level posed by the sinkhole and
its bizarre residents. Finding themselves
in a large cave, the team followed the
sounds of running water to a wide stream,
the water a yellowish-grey in coloration. They
also detected the sound of numerous voices,
all whispering in Russian, but found it too
difficult to distinguish what they were saying.
There were remains too, of some kind of structure
that seemed to indicate the existence of sentient
life within SCP-3667. There was a portion of
a wall, even a hallway, that led into a large,
windowless, circular room. The floor of this
chamber featured an elaborate mosaic, that seemed
to have sustained some damage. But it depicted
anomalous creatures, including some that looked
like the first winged monster that had appeared.
After splitting up down various corridors, two
members of Team One encountered a new entity from
within SCP-3667. This creature resembled a large
feline, but had no eyes, and was about ten meters
in height. It referred to the MTF operatives as
‘sinners’ and foolish mortals who should have
stayed in their cages. Despite being eyeless,
the creature observed that the Team did not
possess what it called the ‘Mark of Ognyena’,
and remarked that they should not have been
there. Feeling threatened by the creature,
MTF Chi-5 Team One were able to blow it
up with a grenade, before being safely
retrieved by their fellow Foundation personnel.
Exploration into SCP-3667 was then resumed by
MTF Chi-5 Teams Two and Three, who were alarmed to
hear what sounded like a human scream coming from
somewhere within the caves. While they first
assumed it was another SCP-3667-1 creature,
someone suggested the possibility that
a civilian could have stumbled onto the
site of the Mirny mine before the Foundation had
arrived and established a secure perimeter around
the sinkhole. Hearing the scream a second time,
this time further away, the MTF agents decided to
investigate, just in case an innocent person had
been dragged underground by one of the creatures.
Passing through a basin of the same strange fluid
that Team One had discovered, the MTF Teams could
hear more unsettling sounds coming from deep
within the caverns. In particular, a repetitive
scratching noise… Next, they discovered a large,
intricate wooden structure, a circle with one side
that appeared to be winched open. Inside, they
could see rows of wooden spikes, covered in a
dark liquid that everyone assumed was blood.
Hearing whimpers from their supposed missing
civilian, the team’s commander decided to call a
retreat. It was then that the MTF realized there
were over twenty more wooden structures nearby.
Each was of a different shape and size, but all
of them were covered in rats that were staring at
the Foundation operatives. These various pieces of
wooden apparatus seemed to resemble… torture
devices. And some of them had bodies inside.
The MTF agents thought they had discovered the
grisly fate of their missing civilian. Little
did they know that things were far worse than they
first seemed; the bodies in the torture devices…
…were still alive.
The Foundation soon realized that there were
upwards of twelve thousand people within SCP-3667,
and immediately began efforts to rescue as many as
they could. Luckily, they had established
a field base on site in the mine, close
enough to the sinkhole that led into SCP-3667.
However, the unfortunate reality was that saving
all of these trapped human beings was no small
undertaking, and space at their nearby base,
Site 574, was limited. Only one hundred and fifty
of the people were able to be recovered and were
transported to Site 574. Those that were had been
found trying to escape from SCP-3667, or being
eaten by the various nightmarish creatures below.
But what quickly became apparent was that these
people, those safely recovered from SCp-3667
and those still trapped within, weren’t exactly
ordinary. When Team One had discovered the strange
yellow-grey stream in SCP-3667, they had collected
a sample of the fluid for analysis. Examining this
sample revealed an anomalous molecular structure,
that would actively bond with organic matter. And
this same unidentified molecule was present in
the bloodstream of the human beings found
beneath the sinkhole. It seemed to have
bestowed each one of them with an anomalous
ability for a limited form of regeneration.
Their bodies could withstand far more damage than
an average, non-anomalous human. The Foundation
even experimented with introducing the anomalous
molecule into the blood of other test subjects,
but it didn’t have the same regenerative effect.
It was assumed that the regeneration was linked
directly to some other factor, and the molecule
from the fluid only acted as a catalyst. As such,
every person recovered from the caverns was
given the collective designation of SCP-3667-2.
Now, various subspecies of strange creatures and
a group of people whose bodies could regenerate,
both living in a system of caverns beneath
Mirny, Sakha Republic. Not to mention all the
wooden torture devices that were being used on
the SCP-3667-2s. Just what the hell was going on
here? And what was it that made this discovery
one of the Foundation’s darkest secrets? Well,
the answers to that could be discovered in
what they learned next about the anomalous
people they’d recovered from the sinkhole.
As the Foundation continued its examination,
their researchers at Site 574 happened upon a
startling realization. The SCP-3667-2 people were
perfect physical and genetic matches to former
residents of the nearby town of Mirny. In fact, of
the over twelve thousand total, only one thousand,
three hundred and twenty-eight didn’t appear to
correspond to any known person from the area. But
then, thousands of others all had proof of their
existence that the Foundation was able to recover
from the town’s public records. Dates of birth,
names, former places of residence, family,
and next of kin… along with dates of death.
The SCP-3667-2 instances all claimed to
have spent their entire lives underground,
beneath the sinkhole where they were tortured
endlessly by nightmarish creatures. Their
bodies could regenerate the external damage
they received, meaning the torture would go
on for days, months, or even years at a time.
When sampling bodies buried in local cemeteries,
the Foundation discovered that these were,
in fact, copies of deceased residents. But
not everyone who had lived and died in Mirny.
Only those whose families had lived there for
at least two generations, and who – while they
were alive – were suspected of committing a crime,
but never convicted. There was one other
unifying factor too: during their lives,
these residents all had some affiliation with a
particular religious group known as the Light of
Five Heavens Russian Orthodox Church.
To put it simply: SCP-3667 was Hell.
Following a number of other incursions
involving SCP-3667-1 creatures, the Foundation
was eventually able to open negotiations with
the entities in order to ensure the continued
stability of SCP-3667. The former director of Site
574, Ndeye Bocoume, was appointed as the ‘Director
of hell’ and placed in charge of overseeing
the anomaly. Under her watch, the Foundation
would supposedly be relocating the displaced
SCP-3667-2s to safe, classified locations
where they could be reintegrated into society.
However, in an email from the Director of hell,
she proposed a solution to the Foundation’s
dwindling number of D Class Personnel.
“I’m happy to announce that something
has come up that changes that – I’ll be
sending each of you a shipment of new D-Class
come next week. It isn’t as many as you had
hoped for, but rest assured, these ones will
withstand most anything you throw at them…”
Now go and check out “SCP-3000 - ANANTASHESHA”
and “SCP-096’S SAD END!” for more!